ミーハー最近運動はしてるかいこれはしてないよって子が最近めちゃくちゃ運動しない
理由なんですよ
もう1年くらい運動しなくてもう最近体の衰えが本当に感じられて非常にヤバイすぐ
疲れるんですよなにかしてても私はちょっとまずいと思ってきたんで今日家でもできる
陰部をしようと思います皆ポールダースといいですね俺な
そりゃねせないかでテレビとかで見たことによって氷があるんですけども
コール兄ちゃん家女の人がこうやってなんか
だでしょ
神根セクシーな奴なんですよボールだすって行こう
んはぁっ
こんな雨ですねこれなんでこんなポール進行やってな購入するやつがあるんですよ
今日は実際にポールダンスお家でやるために突っ張りもう済みしました
おっとて油絵からまた失敗するだろうとか言うなんて何個ね失敗しないぞいままで写っ
パイ後は重力を感じた
今回は重力ジャン今回はめちゃくちゃな
なやつ準備したので重量か関係ねえとしたを止めればいいんだけど
今回も確実に成功させましたよこれはボールはぁスイーツを塗ったりするから突っ張り
ボッシュは区絶対失敗するみたいなイメージがあるんですけどもう
今回は違いますよほとんどで順序よく使わないからねしっかり締めれば拡充にポール
ダンスができるはずですし
つ今までの事があるかかなり強火にしておきます去年は何かツヴァイ号で一世を風靡し
たからたまに初心に帰って
すっぱりおっしゃった
完璧です
いっ
んん
うーん紙本まずフォーレダンスってもやったことないから何から始めていいか分かんだ
よ
なんかこれ風邪じゃないか
の
ああああああ
r
ポールガス関係ないはこれでなった住んでこういうことするんですね
teame
ホール yeah
4 b 2
しています